welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and we have a huge
bit of Man of Steel news coming out of
San Diego comic-con so as of today we
have confirmation that Brandon Ralph the
start of Superman Returns will be back
as the Big Blue Boy Scout in CW's
upcoming crisis on Infinite Earths
crossover event
Ralph took over the mantle from
Christopher Reeve and starred as the
titular character in the direct sequel
to Superman to you which was directed by
Bryan Singer now upon its release the
movie kind of got slammed a bit and a
lot of people said it was very dull even
though it got good reviews it turned a
modest profit and it's pretty much the
reason that DC decided to go so action
heavy with Man of Steel Bryan Singer
also diverted from the x-men franchise
to make this so yeah he kind of ruined
two comic book franchises and his own
career but I actually enjoyed Superman
Returns even though I think it really
works best when you watch it immediately
off the back of the original Christopher
Reeves films so I am quite excited with
this news now what's so amazing about
this announcement is that we might
finally get some closure to what
happened to the character as a lot of
things will left open-ended with us kind
of being left wondering what would
happen to his son who two possessed his
abilities this will be the first time
that Brandon Roth has worn the cape
since 2006 so it definitely feels like
it's been a long time coming there's
actually already been a reference to his
Superman in the arrowverse when Ray
Palmer jokingly said that Supergirl
looked a bit like his cousin so yeah
it's a nice tie back to that as well now
crisis on Infinite Earths will air in
December in January on the CW and it's
rumored to pay off pretty much
everything that's been set up with the
multiverse and all of the shows so far
the event is due to take place over five
episodes and it will bring together
arrow the flash Supergirl legends of
tomorrow as well as Rudd Superman I'm
really excited for this and I can't wait
to see how it goes down and Ralf will
obviously smash it and I really think
that this will be the perfect send-off
for the character
it's gonna be pure fanservice and
honestly I think it'll be amazing now
I'd love to hear your thoughts on this
news and if you're excited for it or not
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please like it and
make sure you check out one of the most
savage put downs at a Comic Con ever
which would be linked at the end
basically it's Anthony Mackie completely
destroying some fans and yeah it's
definitely worth watching I'll leave
that linked at the end and hopefully
I'll see you over there after this I
also just want to let you know that
we're giving away a free copy of
Avengers endgame on blu-ray and all you
have to do is like this video make sure
that you subscribe to the channel and
give your thoughts on the brand and
route Superman news in the comments
below the winner will be chosen at
random on August the 10th and the
blu-ray will be shipped out from there
whoever get surprised it's the best of
luck to everyone who takes part this is
a channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]